what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch The
Last of Us episode six today of course
joined Mama one and only Andrew Andrew
my one and only how are you Mr Igor
7-Eleven I'm doing great I'm really
looking forward to the continued journey
of Ellie and Joel off to Mordor I'm
looking forward to it
I thought you were gonna say I was
looking forward to Henry and Sam's
Journey no I think it's too soon for
that I think I overshot that joke when I
did the bill and Frank one so I I wanted
to give that one a rest for this week
maybe next week I'll come back with that
one yeah we'll see what characters die
next alrighty guys well you know the
drill leave a like I got a g fuel in my
hand if you want 20 off G fuel go to the
promo code in the description box reject
Nation it's not a sponsored video but
hey it's always a nice perk that you can
get from the real rejections and I'm
always drinking these things you know
subscribe click that notification Bell
because we only got a couple of episodes
left on this show I can't believe it
it's coming around the corner full
length Reaction watch along as we sync
up with your own copy of The Last of Us
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page we cover
several things exclusively over there as
well appreciate everyone who's been here
your support has been not overlooked
that sentence could have been said
better let's see what's going on it's
like an hour long let's do it
community
ah winter uh time Jump yep same text
from the game
oh dead animals well that's how it
started in the winters that's why
[Music]
Tatanka from Dances with Wolves who the
hell are you take the gun out two
fingers only put it Out Of Reach
he didn't hurt me by the way yeah
he's got a girl with him can I come down
no
what did I just say Joe come on they're
like a thousand I need you to tell us
where we are if you got a map while
you're lost you must have missed all the
street signs in the enormous Forest holy
we're somewhere here exactly where and
your answer better be the same as your
wives
yeah are you telling me the truth
I love this couple they've got an
interesting Dynamic actually you haven't
heard the name Tommy nope
those in the summer not the Bugs
there are Firefly people
they're delivery
you got any advice on the best way west
yeah
go east
if your brother's west of the river he's
gone
laughs
what's going on
[Music]
TST just remind you that you're dead
fine he's having a panic attack
[Music]
if he did have a panic attack he sure
recovered quick
[Music]
it's always been my favorite in the game
when it's cold weather right oh yeah
that's my favorite section too for sure
ah
you are something else Gustavo so good
I'm starving I should have stolen two
rabbits we can get our own rabbits
dude some of these locations are just
gorgeous hmm
oh what just to warm up
[Music]
so gross
still gross get the reference yeah you
can do anything you want what are you
doing
an old farmhouse some land
um cool what kind
quiet
[Music]
what about you where are you gonna go
everyone else to look what up
I read everything I could in the school
library I think Neil Armstrong Buzz
Aldrin you know who my favorite is
Charlie Ryan Sally [__] ride
best astronaut name astronaut yep it'll
work right the vaccine it's a little
late to start wondering
I tried with Sam I knew he was infected
I was wondering if they talked about it
I rubbed some of my blood into his bite
I wanted to save him
[Music]
get some sleep dream of
sheep ranches on the moon That's The
Last of Us Part 3 is about
laughs
still mumbling in your sleep
you can't do things like this but I can
because I just did I'm responsible for
you okay then don't fall asleep
I look for tracks I found the high
ground and I kept watch like you taught
me to what can I say man I'm a natural
it sounds more and more like Ellie
slowly becoming indiscernible
that's gorgeous
[Music]
oh he's trying to whistle I'm learning
how to whistle
sound like I know how to whistle
seriously though how the [__] do you do
that
you should teach me how to hunt not so
sure about the dressing what's the
dressing why don't we take the guts out
oh yeah why do they call it dressing
it's like you should call it undressing
because it is it's like
undressing
oh here we go damn ah so that made
electricity
no you could have just made something up
I wouldn't believe you
foreign
looking for any trouble we're just
passing through
out the gun
think five steps back how about we just
talk this through how about you shut the
[__] up okay
damn who are these guys I think I have
an inclination but I don't want to spoil
there's no
[Music]
oh no don't go to Ellie like I said
we'll just move on
now her oh
oh damn that dog's being dick
[Music]
ah yes it is the PTSD you're right
[Laughter]
oh
[__] boy never felt so much attention
just looking for my brother it's all
nothing more
oh damn is that okay uh yeah what's your
name
Joel starts with an m so you're thinking
yeah
it is okay all right yeah I couldn't
tell if it was Tommy's people or not
that's what I meant when I said I had an
inclination yeah
oh it's so cool seeing live action
holy crap he has yes
wow [__]
[Music]
um that's a surprise
oh I love it
I was not expecting it not at all be
this
Thomas
[Music]
let me guess it's the same shirt he wore
Paul's gonna let us know
yeah that is the same jacket
from the second game
[Music]
here to save you
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow this is this is really surprising
it's been a while since we've had a
proper meal actually I don't think I've
ever had a proper meal this is [__]
amazing
oh yeah
what
I heard no way
I was kids around here don't usually
look or talk like you oh I can't believe
it what is happening right now a bad
reputation doesn't mean you're bad not
always at least
he's from True Blood we're grateful for
your hospitality and all would it be
nice to have a moment here maybe just
for family
oh
Maria is Family actually
oh [__]
[Laughter]
don't say congrats congrats
we've settled here about seven years ago
just a handful of us back then welcome
to Jackson all this Open Country out
here
turkey shoot I still got my 700 but I
found a variable Power Scope sub MOA has
he sounds so Tommy how do you keep this
place quiet carefully being in the
middle of nowhere helps it's not
advertising what we have staying off the
radio snowball fight we draw power from
a dam got that working a couple years
ago after that sewage Plumbing water
heaters
bites oh holy [__] this city doesn't
exist till the second game so it's just
kind of like darling to see it all here
and then of course some other characters
who won't spoil no wonder
I'm on the council democratically
elected
everything you see in our town [__]
Collective ownership
so uh communism it is that literally
this is the commune we're Communists
no way a couple months old you want a
pet her ah what's your name Shimmer
[Music]
oh whoa
dude this is too much well I'll take
Ellie over there if you two wanna catch
up yeah okay
this is
such a shock yeah I was not expecting
this to either get over it gotta Reserve
so many things oh yeah we got to be very
careful with what we say afterwards
whatever doesn't seem like you age much
you on the other hand
thanks for still giving a [__] about me
Christmas trees and bake pretty decent
setup recognize where they're at so
how's Tess
is fine uh running the kid she's the
daughter of some fire flying monkey muck
trying to find her family somewhere out
here so you know where they might be
these fireflies you know they got a base
down at the University of Eastern
Colorado
yeah I can't go well because your wife
won't let you no she's the one who kept
you off the radio
am I the wrong people Joe how many
things I did tell me those things that
you judged me for come did those things
to Keep Us Alive
we murdered people
and I don't judge you for it
we survived the only way we know how uh
if you knew the [__] that I've been
through Tommy trying to find you these
last few months I'm going to be a father
what three is a few months long now
[Music]
stop oh God but I don't know why
I guess we'll find out oh man I guess
we'll find out what else am I supposed
to say
[Music]
dude Pedro is such a good actor just
because life stopped for you
it doesn't mean it has to stop for me
[Music]
I'll grab some supplies and be out of
your hair in the morning
damn just that distance between them go
searching for him and then Brothers
Living the best life ever
[Music]
dude does Jackson have a therapist
strayed from the game the music
[Music]
oh
man
no
gross
foreign
oh are they gonna give us the scene that
we don't actually get in the game
Kevin and Sarah oh she have a kid too
before go ahead try it on it's uh super
[__] purple
who's been cutting your hair
world-class salons
I was an assistant district attorney I
put bad guys in jail
I'm sorry about your kids it's okay
I'm kid just Kevin
Sarah was Joel's daughter yeah we did
get it wow there are clearly things you
don't know about Joe oh like how he used
to kill people I know about that so then
you understand my concern he doesn't do
that anymore he stopped killing people
innocent ones and Tommy did it too you
worried about him
touche Tommy was following Joel the way
you are now wow maybe I'm smarter than
Tommy no offense oh
Dude Love belly be careful who you put
your faith in
the only people who can betray us
are the ones we try
interesting I understood where they were
going with that
just met Lucy what did you tell her I
was moving I'm Legit mesmerized right
now I'm just like yeah wow they're doing
all this right now and they're obviously
making bold choices and new choices
um wow oh dude look the whole Workshop
yeah you've had people go that way and
come back in all of them
what is this
oh
she's immune there it is she couldn't
pick it but she didn't get sick I saw
her get bit myself
that was months ago months she's in yeah
they really do feel like brothers she
made me swear to take the kid
who was her dying wish what the hell was
I supposed to do
we made it as far as Casey you know she
saved my life there
from another kid
five years ago I would have destroyed
him yeah but she had to shoot him to
save me because I was too slow and too
[__] deaf to hear him coming I
acknowledged it today I thought that dog
was gonna tear apart oh so far
completely there are these moments where
the fear comes up out of nowhere stilted
my heart
paralyzed what kind of dreams
I don't know
I just know that when I wake up I've
lost something oh I'm failing him asleep
it's all I've ever done
it's failure
ouch I'm just gonna get her killed I
know I mean it's what you took off on me
right
to make up for the things we did
yeah
you're younger than me you're still
strong you said it yourself you'll come
back
you have to take her
if anyone else sees those bites on her
what's under her skin she'll shoot her
to the last thing I'll never ask
[Music]
I'll take her out of dawn
I like these enhancements
[Music]
this is really all they had to worry
about
boys movies
[Music]
deciding which shirt goes with which
skirt nice
bizarre
I came here to talk to you no why are
you still here if you're gonna ditch me
ditch me
you know I stood up for you today
because I thought
he knows the area better than I do you
give a [__] about me or not of course I
do then what are you so afraid of
I'm not her you know
Maria told me about Sarah and no don't
say another word
I've lost people too
you have no idea what loss is
buddy I have cared for has either died
or left me
everybody [__] except for you
so don't tell me that I'd be safe with
somebody else because the truth is I
would just be more scared
you're right
you're not my daughter
and I sure as hell ain't your Dad we're
going our separate ways
[Music]
I think it's a brilliant adaptation man
yeah brilliant
how they choose to bring these certain
scenes to life yeah but when to use it
and the slight changes to make brilliant
I thought that was the I was scared I
like that they play more into Joel
falling apart yeah
you can't really say goodbye or
something no I came here to steal one of
these horses and go I would have gave
you one
you deserve a choice I still think you'd
be better off with Tom let's go okay
okay
there's just things that happened at
this show make me so happy
[Music]
there's a place for you here both of you
can I borrow that
yeah
because Maria took mine you know
I'm talking about my wife
's Big Brother
oh yeah
you ride that horse
[Music]
teacher I think so you're flinching the
target's too small I made it bigger than
I should have eject the cartridge
my food just sucks get it yeah deep
breath in slow breath out squeeze the
trigger like you love it gentle
steady nice and slow you're gonna shoot
this thing or get it pregnant
it isn't gonna work it doesn't aim right
dick
[Laughter]
[__]
wow I think this is the end credits
music in the game
[Music]
I like don't want this episode to end I
know right back then there were
basically two main ways of looking at
things some people wanted to own
everything and some people didn't want
anyone to own anything at all which one
were you
neither I just did my job
we were called contractors
it's a contractor
[Music]
yeah
yeah we're cool
everybody loved contractors
great shot don't end please don't end
feel you ending okay
well to the other team are you talking
about football it's called a turnover
yes
yes in One Direction
I made it in five days I don't know what
Tommy was so afraid of still time to
find out it's your time to find out
contractor
Colorado
wow holy [__] they've done it
this way
[Laughter]
wow
people would live here and like what go
to classes and stuff yup even though
they were adults sort of adults
I think it was just as much about
partying and finding themselves as
anything else
I don't want a sheep Ranch actually I
mean if the dealers I can do anything
that's the deal well when I was a kid I
wanted to be a singer
why is that funny
you gotta sing something now come on now
I'm not gonna laugh you're already
laughing oh will you sing for me later
I'm Gonna Save the [__] world man
it's the least you can do for me
fair enough
but they get to see their faces for the
shots like in the game and you're like
fracking behind them are those monkeys
monkeys
first time I've seen a monkey first time
seeing a monkey
love this
ah who's on a piece of wall in the game
but that's good enough
[Music]
this is happening
we'll see you know how this show can be
sometimes
this is coolest there's a vending
machine guys get your health bars
I can list
something you make before moving
oh yeah
haha
[Music]
pulsating ass music rather
yeah at least it ain't clickers yeah no
fireflies either maybe in all that
research they turned into [__]
monkeys
that's where they went all the pins lead
there maybe getting ahead of the weather
I don't know
hear them
[Music]
oh crap we're gonna be getting a cliff
hanging around me yeah we are save it
[Music]
yes the grab from behind
oh nicely done
um
ah yep no
[Music]
oh
nice like a western
[Music]
is there a monkey on Thomas
no
[Music]
Joe
Open Your Eyes Open Your Eyes
without you I don't know where the [__]
I'm going what the [__] I'm gonna do
Joe
please
wow
[__]
job well done so much to talk about Holy
balls and can't talk about the future of
course yeah we got to be careful what we
say but holy [__] that was amazing the
short version is if you've if you've
played both games you'll know why we
were getting excited at certain things
and a certain appearance by what was
clearly
a cameo of a character which we won't go
into because yeah I mean I think the the
main presumption that a lot of people
have had even for those I haven't played
the game is like they're just going to
do the first game
so to see so much like we've seen like
things that are like oh this is
thematically pulled over from the second
game this was like oh this isn't to
happen until the second game like a lot
of this doesn't happen until like way
later this is kind of insane to see this
all brought like the really setting it
up and it it does make sense to me to to
cover some of that and like as much as I
love this episode I I really did love
this episode while it you know was light
on action no infected whatsoever I still
I I do there's one criticism I have that
I'm going to reserve uh I will say it
it's not a spoiler criticism there is
one criticism that I have and it's not
like oh the game did this why didn't you
it's something that I genuinely feel
like I would have had even if I hadn't
played the game and I'm curious
but I don't know I could be wrong about
that I am curious to see if other people
who haven't played the game will have
this feeling
um but regardless as as this uh episode
went
I thought it was so great to keep it
focused on the core wounds of both of
these characters and primarily Joel you
know like seeing the this has been a big
Journey since episode one for him to try
to get to Tommy and when he meets up
with him
like in in the game itself it's it's
relatively light you know it's not
they're like hiding out at a dam
essentially yeah and they got plans for
stuff but this but to see this is a much
more this this hits a more that's why I
like the change because it it
emotionally hits a lot harder when
you're like
I didn't even bother to inform my
brother about this Safe Haven we have
this civilization we are prospering in
we've got animals like literally this is
the most
this this city represents the closest
thing to functioning as normal to before
the outbreak ever happened I'm I'm
married I am having a kid and my brother
I didn't bother to tell about any of
this you know and he's so traumatized by
everything he's been dealing with that
he can't
it's like you could just see the the the
array of emotions that Pedro Pascal's
going through as all this information is
being received the the anger that can be
ha that can be happening from not being
informed or being excluded from all this
information because like one way to
register like my brother doesn't care to
tell me about any of this oh because
you're your wife whatever
you know what do you view me as am I
that much worse of a person and then
also the life that he's having is the
life that Joel has repressed you know
because you never thought something like
Jackson could be possible and everything
with Sarah that entire lifestyle is a
thing he has just been in been in denial
over and anything that comes close to
the surface of it just sends him into a
panic attack State and I thought
breaking that down in this episode where
he's just coming head on of having to
leave Ellie behind a moment where Ellie
could be killed and he freezes up having
to confront his brother all all that
coming to the surface to then get to a
transitional point for this character
where clearly he's being more you know
playful and friendly and open now with
Ellie just you could see it after the
whole horse ride over to Colorado he's
just so much more
uh lifelike you know he's smiling and
making jokes and opening up to her I
wanted to be a singer and all that even
different than the beginning of this
episode so I thought like as a because
while they do they do skip over a lot in
the game like they do like don't get me
wrong they they do there's some stuff I
would have liked to have seen the whole
damn sequence yeah yeah yeah I mean this
was a nice surprise even the you know
the escape from the University yeah it
was much more shorter in this version
yeah whereas in in the game it is very
much like you have to go through some
bad guys and then when he gets uh
injured he gets like throw he gets
knocked through a window and it lands on
him he falls off the guard rail and then
lands on a like a a pipe thing that's
sticking out yeah okay yeah it wasn't a
window yeah I just remember that I'm up
on the floor and he fell which I'm sure
in like a real life live action if we
might be like would you have survived
there yeah well I thought that came too
but yeah yeah that's what I mean
um but it's much more intense having to
like really help him to escape where
here they take a much more subdued
approach uh to it
um
but that's not even my complaint uh but
before I even say what that is Andrew
first I want to give myself a little pat
on the back I made that joke about the
very beginning in my intro where I said
you know they're on their journey to
Mordor and then we got a couple fake
outs at the ending where you've seen
Return of the King you know exactly what
I'm talking about that movie's the king
of fake outs when it comes to endings I
agree with that just the amount of
traveling too feels like very Lord of
the Rings yeah yeah well of course of
course I just meant that it's just
interesting I make that point when an
episode has multiple endings it felt it
felt like but uh not a complaint right
just an observation but I agree with
everything you said I felt like you know
the changes that were made here or not
even changes so much like the more it
was just a lot more emotionally drawn
out and a lot more dramatic like yes you
did feel that Joel was afraid of you
know being that protector that Ellie
needed in the game but here it's a lot
more dramatic a lot more drawn out
especially that scene he has with Tommy
like I really felt a lot more
emotionally invested in that see not
that I don't love that scene in the game
it's really good in the game but it's a
lot more lighter in tone whereas this
it's a lot more dramatic you feel like
because they set up the whole PTSD
moment it really LED lens Credence to
the moment that we get here and it's
just again just to clarify you're
talking about when he when Joel does
open up and is asking
um yeah yeah yeah Greg listen great
sorry I was distracted myself
but yes no I just I appreciate that and
I got it at everyone who acted in the
especially Gabriel Luna damn that man
just sounds so much like it's just it's
ridiculous I'm almost think like Jeffrey
Pierce is dubbing from but I know he's
not but it's just so much it's really
incredible but I really gotta tip my cap
to Pedro Pascal and and belly she is
the level of depth that she goes to when
it comes to emoting and just the uh the
emotional balance that she has as an
actress it's just incredible like the
scene for instance just at the very end
where Joel Falls over straight out of
the game and you know you do get Ellie's
pleas of Joel trying to wake up in the
game but again here it's I like that
they draw it more out like you really
feel it here yeah in the show uh like
you know where she starts crying and
like saying I don't know where to go I
don't know what to do and again that was
in the game but again it's just drawn
out it's more dramatic here and I really
feel it you know emotionally to my core
a lot more here which I appreciate and
again yeah this this episode no clickers
no infected I mean a little sad about
that always whenever we don't get
infected but again with what we were
dealing with from you know Joel's
perspective in terms of the PTSD yeah
they did you know again that was touched
upon in the game where he had a fear of
you know not being able to protect Ellie
but again the way it's portrayed here by
Pedro Pascal I mean just again the level
of depth that he goes through as an
actor is just it's really really
incredible and I just didn't think he
was able to go to that level and I just
really appreciate it and again just
seeing Jackson I was not expecting that
in a certain possible character or not
possible we a certain character that we
did get that was awesome I thought there
was going to be another one that I think
you know who I'm talking about that we
didn't get uh but that was really cool
that they did that
um and yeah I know this episode I mean
if you're if you're a fan of the game I
really feel like most fans of the game
are really gonna love this episode give
or take a couple little things that they
skipped over in terms of the dam and the
University of Eastern Colorado but for
the most part and obviously the way they
figured out that they're at St Mary's uh
well said it in Utah rather I'll just
say that the fact that they found that
out on a map it was a little different
in the game where they found out on a
voice recorder from a guy one of the
doctors or something uh the fireflies
that was still uh that had died there
not a big deal I don't think that's
going to bother too many gamers so I
think this what I loved again about this
episode is the expansion uh the the the
good changes that they made but also
like you're gonna in my opinion you're
gonna appease uh Gamers with this
episode but you're also gonna piece
people who haven't played the game in
just like good damn television and I
think this episode really did a good job
of that when you talk about an episode
that is more on the dramatic side and
less on an action side when you're
thinking of something in a
post-apocalyptic world and I also to got
to give Credence and and uh applaud to
the the cinematography and the locations
in this episode and the way they use the
snow in the background and all in the
foreground and all that was so damn
beautiful I mean these locations were
freaking amazing it had a great sense of
atmosphere throughout the entire episode
and uh we got to hear more of the the
tracks from the from the games as well
uh yeah I thought this it's helped build
out the world even more which was
excellent and you know I I do want to
speak I do really want to speak on from
like game comparison in a way in a way
that's very complementary to the show
because the there are certain scenes in
here
that are yeah that that scene is in the
game but when it occurs in the game is
very different and the placement I'm not
just talking because I had like a bunch
of other stuff or something like that
it's the lead into the scene is so
different that it re-contextualizes a
lot of the scenes like for example that
moment where you're talking about with
um where where Tommy learns about Ellie
that happens pretty early much earlier
on when when he does reunite with him at
the dam and and in the game he's not
even searching for Tommy you know he's
not even like looking for him right no
they were looking for Tommy they were
nobody left for he was looking for Tommy
for to get to the fireflies right yeah
well because he wanted to drop Ellie off
at Tommy so he could take her to the
fireflies yeah but like I mean in the in
the game it's it's more so they they
have had a falling out of sorts correct
whereas in the show he's like I haven't
heard from my brother I'm worried about
him I need to refined him correct that's
the difference with with this correct he
enters here worried like I don't know
what's happened to him and I'm afraid he
might be dead yes so they even have that
scene that's not in the game at all with
uh that Native American couple at the
top of this which I thought was a great
scene by the way
um but when he does tell him you know
they have that that conflict first where
he doesn't open up to him or they get
into a fight and then he eventually
tells him and whereas in the game he He
Still Remains a lot more hardened but
gets a little soft here
it's it boils down to he feels like he's
not good enough I feel like she will die
in my hands which I think adds just so
much more weight to this character
development of a guy who's having to
overcome so much rather than I'm just
more than just I'm afraid of connection
which he all which Pedro Pascal already
brings to this character it's a fear
that he will repeat the same mistake
that happened with Sarah which I thought
made it so much more impactful and where
to place it in this episode and with the
context of how they built Jackson he's
gonna be a dad I think makes him telling
Tommy and asking that favor of him so
much stronger
um and even the scene where Joel and
Ellie uh they where they do have that
confrontation where he's like you're
right you're not my daughter that whole
scene so much of that is like I'm like
I'm sure most of that was just like work
dialogue from directly from the game yes
it was but when that occurs in the in
the game it's it's the lead into that is
very different much different whereas
here it's a lot more of a solemn like
we're gonna say bye she learns about it
and then you know she's like like her
chilling in a room that's that's not the
case in in the game right and
it emphasizes the dramatic moment more
and because you had the scene prior
where you're seeing that he's not just
being some hardened [__] who's who's
like I just no I I I gotta treat her
like she doesn't matter to me
where he because I don't think in the
game
he doesn't tell her I care about you
does he tell does he say that line
that's the part that stood out to me
where he says do you even care about me
and he says of course I do is that in
the game that's the part that stood out
to him if it is I'm not remembering
right now but I I don't recall that in
the game because other than that line
I'm like everything else sounded like it
was from the game for the most part
everything else was yeah from the game
because he's coming in to that scene
already much more vulnerable
versus how he was in the game so
you know like when he gets hurt by what
Ellie's saying then his defense
mechanism Rises back up and says that
and I I like the way the context is
displayed here a little bit more
actually because some have criticized
the Pedro Pascal portrayal I've heard
some of it of being being a little bit
softer
um yeah no he's not as much of a
hardened [__] he's definitely got
more of the depression wearing in his
eyes people skipped over the scene where
he was beating the crap out of that
guard with uh yes but I don't know I I
like I really love what they do uh for I
really love what they do like the
criticism that I had was
I wish
because because of the fact that what
you because one thing that this show
does that's really cool to me because a
lot of those moments where you see us
getting excited like when they're on the
horse that you're still doing you're
still doing gameplay in those scenes
when you're playing the game right so
it's a tracking shot of of behind so
you're not actually it's not a cut scene
but the dialogue is still happening
whereas here they get to treat it more
like a cutscene where you can actually
focus in on the characters you could see
their faces see their reactions so I
think that's really cool that they're
taking moments where the dialogue change
happens during game play and you get to
make a whole scene out of it yeah yeah
so you can really focus on the actors
and I think it's really cool very true
uh but with that so much of the bonding
between Ellie and Joel happens during
the gameplay and not necessarily
cutscenes
and I wish we had more of them bonding
together but before getting to this
moment where they might split apart
that's the one part of this that even if
because so much of that bonding happened
off screen that all happened was in that
three-month period you know that we
didn't get a z and what will help make
up for that is the fact that I really
felt like the actors Pedro Pascal and
Bella Ramsay they really brought their a
game and built whatever that three-month
history was together because you can see
their relationship changed you can feel
that the relationship change and the way
they interact has really changed so yeah
I like I buy it I just feel like I I
still I still do feel that even if I
didn't play the game I'd be one I'd be
left going I wish we got to see them
bomb more before we get to the episode
where they might split apart you know
yeah I I get what you're saying I mean I
think this episode really nailed like
again not the cut scenes but the scenes
where you are actually in control you're
seeing more of the back of their heads
and then you have that dialogue where
they are bonding so they really did nail
that in this episode so I mean no I get
where you're coming from I mean I just
think their performances have been just
so freaking good that that hasn't
bothered me as much but if obviously if
they had expanded a little more you know
with them bonding I'm not gonna complain
I'm always down for some belly and Joel
so I mean ideas the last episode they
had just started really bonding yeah you
know what I mean no I I get what you're
saying I'm not saying I disagree I'm
just saying it hasn't I I guess it
hasn't bothered me as I'm not saying
it's bothering you like crazy or
anything but it it hasn't been a thing
that's an issue for me but I I get where
you're coming from I can see where
you're saying and again if they would
have had more scenes like that I'm not I
mean heck yeah I'm down for it for sure
so but that's I think that's a very fair
criticism that that you make I do also
really like that scene that they had
with Maria and Ellie I thought that was
a great expansion in scene because we
didn't get a we I mean at least I I mean
I don't remember in either game where we
heard that Maria had a child and lost
that child so just getting the expansion
yeah so getting the expansion on her
character and then also seeing the way
that she defends Joel like it just like
again that those inner the interaction
that you had with Maria I just I really
appreciated that conversation but I
appreciated more was how she was
defending Joel so quickly and just like
again just how sharp she was in her into
like that just that like that's Ellie it
was just to the T and again we'd never
gotten that scene in the game so that's
what I love about the show and I think
you were just when you're like this is
just how you do an adaptation like they
just know where to pick their poisons
when it comes or rather their strengths
rather when you know they're doing like
a shot for shot thing with dialogue or
imagery visuals you know when it comes
to the game or stuff that they're
expanding upon and I mean they're just
really nailing it on the head for man
again I really like that that uh
expansion we got with uh Maria's
character when she was cutting her hair
which kind of an Easter egg to her
cutting her hair but um well you know
actually the thing about the kid if I
could interrupt for one second yeah
which I think is neat because so much
happens in a world like this is there's
the the trauma bonding element yeah
they're all kind of experiencing a
universal trauma bonding yeah because of
the the thing and both
but then uh but Sarah I imagine in a lot
of ways was like a daughter to Tommy too
so of course of course
um
but the addition to that because that
scene happens whereas like Serato uh
Maria told me about Sarah but that
happens off screen in the video game so
you know the second they went from
someone that's when I said like are we
gonna get that scene
I was like oh we're gonna see how Maria
told him and I think it makes more sense
because it always did kind of
uh I wouldn't say rub me the wrong way
but whenever that came up in the game I
was like
why would that just come up in
conversation with Maria and Ellie I mean
I get what you're saying but didn't they
just to defend the game they Joel and
Tommy were off for a good 15-20 minutes
so we don't know what was exactly talked
about obviously now we do but I I I get
where you're coming from now yeah no I I
just I feel like that's such a we need
to see that conversation we need to see
that little bit because even here Maria
doesn't go into this whole story yeah
yeah she's not going you know like oh
Sarah died in the uh day of outbreak or
something like that and you know she
just realized she had a slip of one one
one sentence and was like never mind
yeah well also I like the guard rails
too on Maria like just being so
protective of Ellie because again like
you talked about just it's such a
traumatic like everyone's gone through
some kind of uh you know trauma so I
think you make a good point there and by
the way you knew that uh I'd get a
little off topic uh you know that Tess
also had a husband and a child that they
didn't you knew about that too or no
um yeah I thought they mentioned that in
the show oh did they okay because uh if
if they did my fault for free game but
apparently they had a deleted scene
where uh they should was like a
flashback where she shot her husband oh
I know that's where I heard it yeah
there was a delivery yeah getting all my
information yeah I'm getting crosswired
here yeah yeah so but yeah my mind went
to that just because we were talking
about characters and their kids and all
that stuff in the drama but yeah getting
back to this episode though like I said
if if you're a big fan of the game I
think there's a lot in here to appease
you notwithstanding the damn stuff that
they that they completely cut out
obviously but I I don't think it was
honestly I don't think that was really
necessary that was more of just action
sequence and the dramatic part from the
dam that they needed they just moved it
over to Jackson which again we got some
really good previews of stuff and
obviously I'm allowed to say this we got
to see Shimmer they even mentioned by
name so as you saw from our reaction and
uh again just uh would have liked the
University of Eastern Colorado a little
bit longer sure but again it's not
something that that's just the gamer in
me but uh I I thought it was completely
fine with the pacing of what they were
doing in the episode so yeah overall I I
really dug this episode it's probably
one of my favorite episodes just I mean
just from the atmosphere the
performances from Bella Ramsay and Pedro
Pascal like just really elevated this
episode to another level on top of all
the things we got previewed to us
um but just and also too just the
moments we got from the game that were
more drawn out more emotional in this
one I mean I just I really appreciated
this episode a lot well I like seeing
how their bond works with them learning
how to hunt together or learn how to
shoot yes yeah seeing these skills at Le
because even though
um
I mean she was taught some stuff in
Federer school yeah uh it's not a big
deal to say that though
I'm like I sometimes I forget like did
the show mention this or not
um even if they didn't mention it yeah
something I mean
and Marlene even said in the first
episode like that I brought I sent you
to federal school yeah you can you can
say that but yeah in federal school like
she'd learn how to shoot but not nothing
like a rifle yeah yeah
um to that degree right so seeing seeing
that
ooh next episode must be yep where we
get some flashbacks too I'm thinking
that too oh there's three episodes three
episodes oh my God
yeah it's either the next episode or
it's episode eight it it could be
episode eight but uh yeah yeah I think
it might be episode eight with the
flashback that you're talking about that
if you're a gamer you know exactly what
I thought they really explore that
because I think we know what's happening
again without going to spoilers we know
what's gonna happen in the next episode
so
um but yeah I mean they go through I do
think that sometimes they skip over some
I sometimes I am I I do get the
impression oh they just saw those
Hunters up but then again it's a lot
less Hunters there's like four Hunters
um sorry I guess there's a scenario yeah
I I actually you know what that might
just be the gamer me too of like
because because not it's not the same
thing as the sniper in the last episode
where you're like how do you just get
around that seriously they could have
had they could have had such a good
moment for attention here yeah even if
I'd hadn't played the game I would have
had that complaint but but I agree but
here you know they see all they see this
Hunters down there or whatever there if
you see them down there and they just
like are able to get to their horse
pretty easily you know and to me just
even as a show viewer I would have been
like oh that would have been some cool
moments to ring out some tension because
I think I think a part of a part of Last
of Us the world that I love about it is
the having to sneak around and then kill
some people and you know having to be
really cautious and I like the stealth
stuff and I think this show is kind of
absent like keeps that not really
present in the game in the show which
kind of that's one element that I'm like
I wish I wish that was here there are
still moments of tension in the show for
sure but there are other parts where in
like that what you just specifically
highlighted that that criticism I will
completely agree with you on that kind
like with the sniper and then exiting uh
Eastern Colorado and then obviously we
skipped a whole tunnel sequence in that
last episode but well even if even if it
was just a show yeah like oh that would
have been such a good moment to ring out
like I would have I would have been such
a good tension sequence I agree but it
goes by quick but that moment with the
dog where she where it was about to
that's good yeah that was great tension
it's like now I want to see that with
people and dogs don't even come into the
second game second game yeah I mean we
see the one dog in the uh in the first
game when they're at the dam and Tommy
says I forgot the dog's name um
I mean the dog wasn't we didn't see him
sniffing or anything but that was it I
mean the other additional scenes that I
I think there's a lot of great addition
because a lot of the scenes are there
are scenes in here that are like that
the whole scene with the dog sniffing
that's not in the game and I think and I
think the enhanced and none of this
stuff with Joel getting emotionally
triggered would become stilted you know
um which uh where he get where he does
get Frozen when the trauma gets too
strong for him yeah that's that's not in
the game either and I think those are
wonderful wonderful add-ons to do to
your show and I agree I think that
there's a lot of see the thing is for
everything that they don't provide for
me from the game they add something else
in here that I'm like I love
that right I love that scene that they
did and it's usually just a character
scene it's not even like they gave me a
different action scene it's some
character scene it's interesting you say
that it's like you did the hard part the
character stuff the right dialogue now
just come up with attention no action
scene
because that's the funny thing is most
video game adaptations just try to do
the action yeah and they don't do the
character stuff but I'm like but they're
doing the most important part because
last of us is really known for its story
and granted we did get an amazing action
sequence in the last episode where the
bloater and all the effects and The
Collector scene in the second episode is
phenomenal yeah yeah for sure absolutely
we've gotten some incredible action
sequences that have been filled with
tension but I agree with you it's those
little moments where it's like it just
adds another layer and again this is not
us saying we hate obviously we're
obsessed with the show it's just
something that we just elevate it to
another level to the stratosphere which
it's pretty much already there as it is
but no like in terms of characters and
all the expansions and that kind of
stuff they've taken this to another
level for sure I think it's only
distracting when like I'm not distracted
if you just skip over it like with Bill
all the [__] with Bill
it doesn't bother me because they just
completely skip past it yeah
so I'm not even really thinking about it
I'll be thinking about it when I'm like
oh [__] we're about to go into that oh
they just kind of like really shorten
the [__] out of that yeah and that's
when I get distracted I agree as someone
who's played the game
um and because then I have to like kind
of check my thought process like is it
just because because like that scene
here at the when they're when the
hunters show up I'm like oh that's a
really tense ass game moment and it's
it's scary and intense at least in that
big dramatic moment right and then here
they literally exit Within
I don't know how long it took like in
the actual context of the TV show but in
screen time it was 10 seconds for us and
there was no tension in terms of the
exiting we're in the game like again
even if we're not Gamers but just
pointing out in the game it it takes a
good while to get out of there yeah
because even finding like the lab stuff
you know you have to really search the
building forever yeah and I'm cool they
skipped that yeah that's cool that's
fine I'm cool with that because it is
kind of just like how do you how do you
find all this [__] again you guys are
like a hassle yeah but but here yeah
it's only just it only it only kind of
like pings that part of my brain when
I'm I agree with when the show is like
about is telling but it basically like I
think they delivered that in the second
episode yeah where with the clickers
yeah with the clickers because there is
that whole sequence of the clickers in
the game and I'm like oh they're
delivering it but they're doing it
differently and they're making it their
own and I do I do get that itch but
again though they're nailing telling the
things that matter more right right of
course of course we could just sit here
and only focus on the on the Praises but
you know like that's what John and Tara
are for on the because they haven't
played the game so they're here to not
even be concerned about it but I agree
with you even if we if we hadn't played
the game I'd still probably say like
okay like we got there pretty fast yeah
they got out of there pretty fast or
yeah no I I agree with you I think it's
a valid constructive criticism but again
like you said they're nailing them the
most important things so that the
characters the emotional depth and
obviously like I've always said from the
beginning if you can nail Joel Nelly
everything else is just icing on the
cake from there and yeah to me for the
most part they have completely nailed
Joel Nelly thus far yeah and there's two
people who actually really love the last
of us too where I know that it's a very
debatable game for a lot of people
um I was over the moon about seeing you
know that there's a divide wait everyone
doesn't love Last of Us Part Two it's
not the same level of overwhelming love
but everyone was obsessed with it the
exact same way as the first game it's
not divided anyway I thought did you
know where you were it's a real thing
yeah it's a problem for people but uh
yeah for me I was like I I was way over
the moon and then seeing that one oh my
God yes like that is a pure Easter egg
oh my god oh for sure it is the purest
of Easter eggs because only if you've
played the second game you know any idea
who your person was you know and it
wouldn't even be a spoiler for me to say
the name
um but I just won't no we're better than
that people we don't wear t-shirts that
spoil game well oh sorry we'll we'll
wait till we're reacting to heavy
spoilers videos yeah we'll let we'll let
Paul do the the spoiling for us and then
we'll we'll expand upon uh certain
cameos and other foreshadowing things
for the future and it is kind of cool to
because I didn't realize that they
because they've obviously changed the
ethnicity of Maria right if you have
like a lot of the characters here um
well just like a few
Joel and the topic okay Sarah but uh
yeah when but it was kind of interesting
to pick up on like because I had no idea
that they that they uh I didn't even
think like who's playing Maria I didn't
even think about that for a second and
but when she started
that might be that might be Tommy's
boyfriend once you said to I mean I was
already thinking that but when she said
is this who I think it is I was like uh
this is yeah I was thinking exactly
that's who I think it is today I love
her work I've seen every season of True
Blood I love her work on True Blood
that's the only thing I'm really
familiar with her on and I I think she's
phenomenal on that show and so to see
her here on another HBO show gets me
really excited and she does bring the
the pr because Maria is like and it's
like a like a warm presence but also a
Stern presence yeah I agree and one last
thing that I want to mention too I
really like how it was just a really
quick scene but I liked that they were
talking about how the town kind of
formed and she was on the council and
all that because
I I know you're you're I mean I'm a huge
fan of the second game you're a little
bit bigger of the fan than I am do you
remember that though that being talked
about in the second game I don't know
man you remember like more trivia stuff
better than I do this is true I just I
don't remember I mean I remember knowing
that her father and her started up the
town but I don't remember talking about
the whole Council and all that I know I
knew Maria was in charge I remember that
yeah I didn't really commit to memory
Maria facts I thought she was your
favorite character in the game dude come
on he just comes and goes in the game
um so either way I thought that was a
nice little introduction to the town and
expansion and just you know how it all
got started and what what they're doing
there so yeah no this this worked for me
on on uh I still I still loved it I I
love I love the hell out of it and then
for things that I thought were missing
from not having
um getting more time with um Ellie and
Joel to bond prior I really feel like
that scene would have just hit a million
times harder if if we had seen them bond
together a little more I no dude I know
I totally I get where you're coming from
it it hasn't bothered again not saying
it bothers you over the moon but I agree
with you would have been nice to get a
few more of those scenes for sure yeah
get a little more time to breathe with
that but
I'm Still Loving what we've got that's
the ironic part it's like I still I
still love the [__] out of this episode
like I I love this episode I didn't want
it to end but I'm not gonna lie to you I
did notice more in this like my brain
was telling me during this like we are
getting so many more scenes in this
episode particularly of not only them
you know forming a bond with each other
like that's obvious but just the the
scenes where you're in control and again
the cameras to the back of your head and
they're just talking like those are some
of my favorite moments in the game and
you're not even there's no action
happening in the game and you're still
in control but nothing's happening but
dialogue and bond building like those
are literally some of my favorite
moments in both games when moments like
that are happening so again I I totally
get where you're coming from I I would
definitely like to see more scenes like
that for sure but so far I've still
loved what we've gotten me too because I
really thought the actors at least
brought the history for the three-month
Gap yeah and and that was another thing
too that I think Pedro Pascal and
Gabriel Luna like they really nail that
Bond ship that they have as others like
you really feel the history those two
have with each other they have such
electric on-screen chemistry together
when it comes to them playing Brothers
with each other and just the way like
how he broke down in front like I I just
I I mean I've had conversations like
that with my brother so like I could
totally relate to that and I just I felt
that between the two actors and just
again this show is so damn well made on
all facets it's just it's really
impressive and the thing with that
moment too of the Christ it was me I
could talk about every every because
there's not a scene here I didn't like
that yeah that's the thing is like I
just wish I had some other scenes yeah
but the with the but even the way he was
doing the crime scene because like
there's many ways an actor can choose to
do something like that and I like that
it wasn't just like him bawling because
Joel this even this interpretation
wouldn't ball like he would be fighting
he was doing everything he can to not
really
cry you know so I like that it was more
of like he's fighting tears it gave me
to a foreshadowing of a future moment
which I know you know what I'm talking
about but we'll talk about it off camera
in terms of the crying yeah yeah yeah I
know I know exactly what he's talking
about
um but yeah uh a great great episode uh
this left me over the moon uh at the end
of the day I was still left over the
moon
I think that was part of the one of my
favorite parts of our reaction to this
episode is like don't and please I mean
I always feel that way when we're
getting towards the end of all these
episodes and obviously to me at least
this particular episode no it was really
do not end yeah please yeah I know like
in the last episode when you kept you
you were probably thinking like more
Kathleen scenes more cats everyone was
thinking that
all right guys well thank you for being
here uh be sure to subscribe three more
episodes to go and uh I can't wait for
this man I can't believe that that is as
a gamer because I I know that doesn't
really I'm sure I really do wonder what
I mean imagine it's still effective for
audience members who haven't played the
second game but for people who are fans
of the second game I'm like wow what a
what a treat oh yeah I couldn't believe
it I couldn't believe it either that was
not this whole experience I was like
this is a shock most shocking and also
too one other thing one as much as I
love HBO Max and and Neil druckman and
all of them I've been a little bit sad
that they've been kind of spoiling some
preview stuff like for next episodes and
stuff so it's I'm just glad like it
allows us to put things in thumbnails
then when they do that that's true and
then I can go well they're showing it
that's true that's true that's true so I
was really like genuinely happy like not
knowing anything about this and like oh
my God not at all expecting that
alrighty well thank you guys so much for
being here
um I had a great time and hey let's end
this with a lucky Pig
Gabriel Gabriel honor Gabriel Luna we
are shouting you out today Gabriel I
hope that this well Valentine's Day has
passed but I hope you had a banger of a
Valentine's Day I hope it was romantic
or at least frisky
and if it wasn't that's even better
trust me you don't want to be trapped
it's like having a constant handcuff on
you
it's disempowering and emasculating
so
she doesn't make us these foreign videos
nor does she watches frame of them so
I'm safe
real
if she asks I love her and I will always
be obedient to her at all costs
um but Gabriel I consider you to be a
very kind soul your name like Gabriel
don't you just gotta automatically
assume they're a nice person I've never
met a dick named Gabriel dude for sure I
mean I mean what's Gabriel Byrne was
evil in end of days but we got Gabriel
and the actor
I know but I'm saying I'm saying we got
Gabriel and the Patriots one of my
favorite characters Heath Ledger so
there you go yeah there you go man
so and Gabriel Luna here is gent as well
and Gabriel in the dictionary means God
is my strength
holy crap
well you know what Gabriel you're our
strength we don't need God we just go to
you so thank you for being you
hope you have a great rest of the 2023
and if you're single go out there mingle
and if you're taken go be shaken and
bacon with her
I don't know I did that Justin I'll see
you buddy
oh